hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to talk
about Toy Story 4 you got a friend in me
so if you've seen any of our trailer
reactions we thought this looked
adorable we thought this looked funny
gonna be fine I did not think it could
be a special film just based off the
marketing I think like a lot of people
very very skeptical were you skeptical
yeah I mean every time they make another
Toy Story I get a little more worried
just cuz the stakes get higher and
judging by the way the ads came out they
looked fun and cheeky but they didn't
really clue me in as to what the true
potential depth of yes I thought it
would go into sequel territory of like a
finding Dory more so than anything else
to my surprise and I think everyone in
the feeder this film is amazing it is an
incredible incredible movie stop this
review go buy a ticket here at Toy Story
fan at all this this is run don't walk
truly just a remarkable movie from
beginning and I was mesmerized like I
think instantaneously the first thing
you notice is I feel like with a lot of
sequels the animation just got a lot
better in other than the toy is but the
environment limited almost the human
world just looks so realistic hitting
the textures on things like grass and
concrete rain and elegance yeah it was
it's really beautiful it was something
else something special in this movie I
can up from where Toy Story 3 left off
the toys are now with Bonnie their new
owner she's a little girl and it's she's
starting kindergarten she decides to
create a little toys it's a little
cuddle buddy because she's not really
favoriting some of the other ones and
she creates this toy called forky which
comes to life played by Tony Hale we
have a toy right here
yay merchandising is real can't tell you
how many people walked out of El Capitan
and went right to the Disney Store but
themselves afford something you
literally could make out of found
elephants we all got one one thing that
our each Fred's and I think all the Toy
Story movies have this similar theme and
their plots is sort of a rescue tale
before he's having an identity crisis of
is essential crazy
if you should be Bonnie's toy or not
which leads to them getting lost and
then they have to get back with Bonnie
which sets on this whole adventure
woody bean in the lead and more so than
anything this feels like Woody's movie
Woody's always been the heart of the
movies he's always been the lead of this
of the films but I think in this
specific installment this is Woody's
movie first and foremost and this movie
is heartfelt there are surprises left
and right there are things that start of
all Vings some toy story plot tropes and
they'll subvert expectations yeah I feel
like there's gonna be a lot of people
saying surprising in yada yada yada
which kind of has me worried if that's
too many people are gonna hear that
they're gonna start really being on the
lookout for things you know I would say
like 30 minutes into this film I started
figuring out okay I think I know where
this movie's actually going to end I
think all of us did yet the ending of
this movie is so damn impactful it
really gets you in the fields I mean I
cried at least twice in this movie a
minimum yeah you know and that's more
than just the ending of this film this
movie is also probably the funniest Toy
Story we've had I think Toy Story 3 was
a lot more on the weight especially
definitely like that's a heavy finale
well this movie I think has definitely a
lot of emotional weight it has a lot to
say about growing up a lot about letting
go some themes that were touched on in
Toy Story 3 or if anything perhaps
expounded upon and in this movie in a
way that made sense any sequel you could
say it's probably just some cash grab or
whatever right what I found interesting
is when you pick up with woody and then
of course Bo Peep it took me a minute to
go oh yeah Bobby's not in Toy Story yeah
it took me a minute to realize that when
you pick up with them I started seeing
oh wait a minute you know what there is
actually some necessity to this movie
there are elements of closure I could
use actually that I didn't even realize
I could use the closure on this I mean
you could argue that no sequel is ever
necessary but this one that was the
biggest concern for me was just are they
gonna make this a worthwhile story and
yeah this this really fired on all
conceivable cylinders really really
funny for just how heartfelt and how
heavy it could be at times and I think
this is a
movie that is really nice because this
Toy Story is aged it has given thought
to messages it can give to the children
in the audience as well as to the
parents in the audience and I feel like
that is also a nice thing because it's
not just that there are jokes or little
nods to pop culture or whatever their
parents are gonna write it's like there
are actual thematic elements that are on
the more mature side you know especially
from Woody's point of view because wood
is such a caretaker in a lot of ways and
kind of a stand-in for that
in nurturing instinct you know and and I
thought too just going out to the
marketing and stuff there are a lot of
elements in here that are easy to look
at in a trailer and go okay there's the
merch they want me to buy and to be
cynical but with four key the way they
handled that character and the gross
personality and handled I loved key and
Peele but especially with keegan-michael
key I feel like sometimes people get a
hold of him and they just don't edit him
at all so sometimes I'm a little worried
when they show up in comedies like this
but I thought they were really funny
some of the best bits that there there
are bits in this movie with those two
characters that I was talking about in
the car ride home just replaying the
whole sequences in my head and I was
dying of laughter repeating it out loud
there's there's just moments of
brilliant comedy in here and even the
villain in the film Gaby Gaby they do
some great things with this character a
lot of this movie I'll say is like you
think they're gonna go down this route
that we've seen in Toy Story before
especially cuz it's another kind of
rescue film man did they I don't want to
reveal anything and of course Keanu
Reeves has do kaboom the key hot Sun so
real like he is having that and it only
hit me like just this week how much of
everything he has got his hands on right
now but yeah he's super charming and if
you don't walk out with a four key
you'll probably walk out with a Duke
kaboom after that because he's a really
funny addition of the story but his
voice performance is great a big help to
the plot to and Toy Story films have
always been great at this and they excel
in this film especially the the physical
comedy the way they do the
animation like it's more than just the
delivery of a lot of the jokes or the
written dialogue like there's just
moments where the characters move a
certain way oh yeah absolutely and of
course they've updated Bo Peep this film
is woke Disney is woke so it's in the
face oh whoa clean oh there's gonna be
you know people who hate feminism who
see that this movie is so within context
of the character and where they pick up
with Bo Peep nine years later it didn't
even actually cross my mind it fits
perfectly with the movie yeah it's
perfect it didn't seem like it was a
studio note or some kind of thing it
just seems like Epoque Peep has been
office this is where the character on
your own and I'm glad they did even if
it was some type of executive woke
decision it makes Bo Peep the best Bo
Peep we've ever gotten you know and
there's also stuff in there that harks
back to the past you know between her
and woody and things like that there's a
lot of dimension from pretty much
everybody who shows up on screen and
nobody is there at least in my eyes to
be just a cipher for one note or message
we want sure across or whatever and yeah
they did a lot of surprising things in
how they handle I know people look back
on some of the previous toy stories and
go oh yeah you can just boil it down to
they're lost and there's an evil toy and
they really took care of this time -
yeah come up with some new ideas for the
story not have a straight-up villain so
much as antagonists ya know and stuff
like that and they managed you to just
come up with something truly unique for
this in a way that I was not expecting
they had some horror comedy bits in here
- there was a couple of people who were
genuinely really creeped out and scared
in certain scenes you know you see those
ventriloquist dolls in the trailers they
do some moments with them that you know
for us it's not scary for kids I can
imagine to be scary either way it's it's
going into the horror comedy route that
I really admire is it was it was
hilarious and the overall direction this
is a different director I think it's his
debut which would be even that much more
impressive the direction here like the
sweeping angles camera shots the whole
scope of it it's it's it's weirdly a
smaller Toy Story film in a way yet it
doesn't feel that way you know
yeah rich there are some roadtrip e I
mean the part of the film centers around
a road trip but it doesn't feel quite as
massive and sprawling like for a lot of
it it does feel oddly well contained in
a couple key location yes you know the
one little criticism I'll give it and
this is just from being a Toy Story fan
this is an actual criticism with the
movie itself like this fourth
installment I was a little bummed from
from a viewer and audience expectation
level even though my expectations I put
pretty low for this film there's a real
lack of Buzz Lightyear in here Buzz and
Woody don't really get much screen time
with all the other toys and her
returning he's definitely the most
featured of them all I admired what they
gave him to do because I thought they
gave him something I wasn't expecting
again he's not just part of the ensemble
and he's not necessarily in a duo with
Woody's so much as he gets his own kind
of solo thread to follow even though
he's a part of the main plot and again
not wanting to give too much away but I
admired what they did while still
agreeing that yeah I wish there had been
more of an actual Woody Buzz dynamic it
made sense why you might have to dial
back some of that because of the
specific story they are telling I don't
think I'll be alone on that I think
there'll be a lot of people who are like
oh I wish we got a little bit more Woody
and Buzz in this movie either way this
film sure as hell lives up to the prior
three installments at god it's not just
a it's a surprisingly good part for it
is just as good I don't know where I
drank it I don't ever try to rank these
movies what I could say that I think
this movie definitely has over the other
ones I think it's the funniest one go
see it it's a great great film and I
feel like there's a lot of word-of-mouth
that's gonna be super super positive
about this I kind of worry that a lot of
online talk people are like I don't know
about this I don't know about this but I
was one of those people I was wrong
whether you're a Toy Story fan or not
really I wanted to end this video with a
patient the day shoutout to a woman
named Jenna
Randolph because this is an animated
movie I just thought this one makes
sense
Jenna Randolph has her own patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin the Golden Circle
cheaper war tears and then she could do
some snail mail art Commission's just
customized for you if you're an amazing
person and
for all your support do you think they
should still make a Toy Story 5 it's at
this point now I'm like well if you
announce it I'm not gonna not gonna
criticize 3 for now I'm like alright you
make a par 5 I'm gonna go home with open
arms but I'm sure you'll figure it out
ideas but this is a spoiler free right
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
catch you guys soon